what are your opinions on
in the recent year or two all of the
different
you know there's been air force pilots
and based in san diego that have come
out and they've had their videos of
these ufos coming out of the water and
within one second being meters away
do you guys pay any attention to that
stuff well i do i mean i cannot speak
for others
and my view on these reports these
eyewitness
reports of unidentified flying objects
ufos that are unusual
my my view is that these eyewitness
testimonies come from
people that are not scientists that were
not
planning to find these unusual things
and
uh we will be better served if we were
to deploy scientific instruments
in those sites and monitor the
environment
um you know i have two concerns about
these reports of ufos over the past
decades
one of them is that now we have cameras
and
recording devices that are far better
than we had decades ago
and back then you know the images were
fuzzy
and it was difficult to be sure that
what it means and so forth
but with present day instruments it
should be crisp clear
uh they are much better than we used to
have and they are still fuzzy and
you know on the margin of believability
uh the second
reservation that they have is there are
far
many more cameras uh available to
monitor environments right now
uh by orders of magnitude you know uh
people have cell phones
you have drones you have cameras on
satellites on airplanes on the in the
streets of cities
and that the the number of uh
video cameras looking at what's going on
is
many orders of magnet larger than it
used to be a decade or two ago
nevertheless the reports on ufos
have not increased uh so that
concerns me that maybe you know all of
these reports were
sort of uh artifacts of the instruments
that were used or
impressions of natural phenomena but i
think that it would be appropriate to
deploy scientific instruments and and
check it out
uh it's really i mean science is about
reproducibility of results
um so one time events are not believable
in science you should be able to
reproduce
them by being in the same environment or
the similar circumstances and
i would trust instruments recording
these events
you know there is this biblical story
from the old testament about
abraham that they heard the voice of god
and
that voice told abraham to sacrifice his
only son
isaac and imagine abraham having
a cell phone with a voice memo up
uh if he could have pressed the button
he would have recorded the voice of god
and then instead of an eyewitness
testimony we would have the recording
and that would have convinced all of
humanity that god exists
uh and so my point is that by recording
things on instruments
you get a much more objective evidence
than all these reports that are now
being declassified from the pentagon and
so forth
we should not obsess with these old
reports that were based on
either eyewitnesses or instruments that
are
much more inferior to the instruments we
have now
we should simply use our best
instruments go to these sites and see
what we whether we see anything unusual
well the pentagon actually said that
they were in possession of some sort of
inter or extraterrestrial craft
on in the new york times article well
what i'm
saying is that it's better you know
abraham said that he heard the voice of
god right so the question is do you
believe abraham or not
i'm saying if he had a cell phone we
could have looked at the evidence
he didn't have that and then you have to
decide whether you believe the biblical
story or not and
the same is true here people report
things and i don't know whether to
believe them so the only way for me to
believe them scientifically speaking
is to deploy recording devices in the
same sites
and see if they find something when you
were talking about 3d printing
and and printing organisms
or basically duplicating ourselves on
other planets
now i've heard reports of of people who
have worked at
s1 and area 51 have
obtained crafts that are very small
saying that only really tiny beings that
have no
reproductive organs is it possible that
other
that other beings are
printing these sort of cadavers
or uh
basically like humanoids but
aliens that can travel long distances
through different solar systems that
don't have to stay alive they don't have
to eat
you know everything is possible and
there are lots of possibilities
outlined in science fiction stories and
the key as a scientist is to look for
evidence
and that should guide you as to which
possibilities are real and which are
illusions or or um
you know our imagination of what might
be out there
uh it's sort of like a detective story
you can have a lot of possibly an
infinite number of possibilities
and you just sort them out and figure
out which one is realized
by collecting clues and evidence you
know
and we could think that we you know we
are wealthier than elon musk
we could have a lot of money and
the only way to figure out what we
actually have is to go to an atm machine
and check it out
and so the atm machine represents an
experiment where you actually
check what you have and
that's what guides modern science
evidence and clues
many times scientists prefer to have
ideas that do not stand up to the
scrutiny of experiments and that's
that's legitimate as long as the ideas
can be tested in principle
uh the frustration i have is that some
parts of the physics community right now
uh you know there are hundreds of people
working on ideas that will never be
tested
in their lifetime and that to me could
be a waste of their time because
it's imagining things that they may not
exist
real quick i wanted to go back to the
mission you just spoke about that's
about to arrive at mars in a couple
weeks now
what is the purpose of that mission
they're looking specifically for
life right so this is the perseverance
mission and yes
uh one of the highlights of this mission
is to search for
signatures of life and there were
previous missions
going back almost 50 years
that had some tentative evidence that
perhaps
there is something in the martian soil
that
is going through metabolism that is
living because
they took a a sample of that soil
and they noticed that there is some
gas coming out of it that may indicate
life and and when they heat that soil to
a high temperature
suddenly that goes away and there was a
suggestion that maybe it indicates that
there is life in that soil
and and so the perseverance mission is
equipped with
all kinds of instruments that could then
search for life that may exist right now
but also search
for life that may have existed before
you know if there were
rivers or or pawns
in the location where perseverance lands
then
there might be some leftover
signatures of life that may have existed
there and
we don't know exactly how it might look
it might be skeletons or something else
but
the idea is to search for it and it
would be very exciting to see what they
find
yeah i mean it sounds like we're doing
everything we can possibly do within our
means to
to do these types of studies and to try
to find extraterrestrial life and to
find out if we're the only ones here
well primitive life i should say because
technological signatures we are not
doing enough that's what i started from